my name's Katherine Mannix and in my
humble opinion
dying's probably not as bad as you're
expecting
[Music]
we've stopped talking about dying we've
stopped mentioning the D words instead
of saying dead we say passed or passed
away instead of saying dying we might
say seriously ill and families don't
understand that death is approaching
when those words are used and that is in
fact a bit of a problem for us and so
now a family will sit around the bed of
somebody so sick that they will be dying
and not know what to say not know what
to say to each other not know what to
say to the dying person and the dying
person doesn't know what to say either
and doesn't know what to expect
wondering whether each breath might be
their last breath
a scene of sadness and anxiety and
despair and in my humble opinion it
doesn't need to be like that at all
we've lost the rich wisdom of normal
human dying and it's time for us to talk
about dying and reclaim the wisdom what
does normal dying look like well dying
like giving birth really is just a
process gradually people become more
tired more weary as time goes by people
sleep more and they're awake less
families can learn when to give
medicines and when to introduce visitors
but sometimes a visitor might happen or
a medicine might be due during that
sleep and that's when we can discover
that a change has taken place it's tiny
but it's really significant and it's
that instead of just being asleep this
person has temporarily become
unconscious we can't wake them up we
can't give them that medicine we can't
tell them that that visitor is here and
yet when they waken later on they tell
us they've had a good sleep so we know
that this coma doesn't feel frightening
that lapsing into unconsciousness just
isn't noticed by us when it happens
so as time goes by people are awake less
and asleep more until eventually they're
just unconscious all the time we would
be so relaxed that we won't bother to
clear our throats so maybe we'll be
breathing in and out through little bits
of mucus or saliva at the back of our
throat it can make a rattly funny noise
people talk about the death rattle as
though it's something terrible but
actually it tells me that my patient is
so deeply relaxed so deeply unconscious
that they're not even feeling that
tickle of saliva as their air bubbles in
and out through it from their lungs so a
very end of somebody's life there will
be a period of shallow breathing and
then one out-breath that just isn't
followed by another in-breath sometimes
it's so gentle that families don't even
notice that it's happened so normal
human dying just a really gentle process
something we can recognize something we
can prepare for something we can manage
and this should be something we can
celebrate this is something we should be
able to console each other with but
because it's become impolite to talk
about dying it's the really best kept
secret in medicine so in my humble
opinion dying is something we should be
reclaiming we should be talking about we
should be consoling each other about
please pass that on
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon